I worked on that idea of yours for my song.
Do you want to hear it?
Yeah.
You got your lyrics handy?
Mm-hmm.
["MEET IN THE MIDDLE" PLAYS]
(SINGING) Get in my car.
I'll drive you through the Canyon,
breathe in Topanga for the day.
When we reach the ocean and we can't go further west,
we'll keep on driving anyway.
Now you go ahead.
(SINGING) I'll take you down to Dollymount
and we'll [MUTED] behind the dunes.
I'll kiss your mouth, all whiskey breath,
and then leave your heart in ruins.
Sing with me.
(SINGING) Maybe we should meet in the middle.
Maybe we could find a little city no one knows.
And if they just gave us a minute on our own,
maybe we could call it home.
Forget the stars of Hollywood or big old houses in Bel-Air.
I can introduce you to the angels of my city.
Oh, we'll find them anywhere.
I'll drag you around town by your ear still ringing
from the rain.
I'll buy you chips and tea and beer
and then I'll crush your heart again.
Maybe we should meet in the middle.
Maybe we could find a little city no one knows.
And if we just give us a minute on our own--
minute on our own--
maybe we could call it home.
Maybe we could call it home.